he's entering its ninth season in the
National Football League in of his first
eight seasons half of them were Pro Bowl
seasons and he is a freshly signed
resigned member or extended member of
the New Orleans Saints three year 52 and
a half million dollar contract extension
signed on June 11th which means Cameron
Jordan is buying good to see you here on
the Rich Eisen show I'm buying breakfast
everybody say that after breakfast I
mean lunch if you're offering lunch
there'll be a more timely offer
breakfast guy you know you're in
Southern California okay good to see you
man how's the summer of Cameron doing
what's going on it's been a blast legit
a blast around the world did you go on a
USO tour I did I did I went on a
honeymoon a year late honeymoon I don't
know how that works let's start with
that first okay so you got when did you
get married last June last June me and
wife he then went from Los Angeles Texas
to New Orleans New Orleans the Paris
pears to Abu Dhabi Abu Dhabi Dubai Dubai
to Beijing Beijing to Hong Kong this is
she
this this year no doubt this is like in
a 13 14 day span she dipped off went
back to LA cuz of our kids because she's
a phenomenal mother yes I mean I was
just you know
then I became cam for a night I went off
to Macau and I gambled I gambled Macau
away which brings in what ten times what
Vegas does and I understand why wasn't
much winning there no kid what's your
game
baccarat if I have time James Bond it
makes me feel it makes me feel
sophisticated what to say you wear a
tuxedo and go in there scream I'm scary
monkey I'm out here looking for face
card but no and then um of course I saw
after McHale went off to created a USO
tour and just you know when you're in
Seoul and you're close to yeah when
you're in Seoul you're close to that the
DMZ air you just realize exactly what
the troops give up and it's like they
put some in such a higher regard of what
you ever had them in and I've been you
know it was my second year so to her my
first year so tour was out in the Middle
East and I did by rain and I did the UAE
and it's just every time you go you just
get a little bit more of what exactly
people
and what what the struggle is and what
they're facing every day and it's why
more along the lines of when I say you
know salute to the Troops it's like
really heartfelt now it's like sure [ __ ]
you you grow up you're like yeah I
appreciate the troops and what they do
for us going over there but you actually
see what they do and the hardships they
go through and you're like I know
everything that they do for us you just
it's a guy it's our god-given
opportunity just imagine you in a tank
right now what are you what are the
players I mean what are the troops ask
you do they add you run into some saints
fans of course I mean there's like
Saints contingencies like it everywhere
we went to every camp we went to there
the Louisiana boys or swamp boys there
you know 504 boys there's always a group
and when I say boys there's men and
women but they're you know but it gets
the moniker is sure people would be
right 21st century you politically
correct five or four people would be the
right group that you'd have to associate
but I mean it's just a lot of love and
it's such the same things just you know
what do what do you do to get your mind
right for a season what is it that you
know that you you partake from when you
were younger to the time you are now
what was that transition period of like
our team going three years of seven and
nine to and now it's being a playoffs
the past two years and you know just the
same questions anybody else would have
and you know they tell you they they
wake up three four o'clock in the
morning just to watch our games I mean
there's about as serious as fans can
ever get and I mean they die hard out
there so nothing but love for it Cameron
Jordan the Saints here in the Rich Eisen
show how often you think about the way
the season ended just every time I get
on a show like this show like this ok
but no yeah I mean we're normally uh
it's if anything I'm always focused on
just this next this next stop because of
the way in it it's like I don't even
want to it's like I don't even want to
focus on how it ended I want to focus on
what I can do to be better
if I could finish every game sort of
like how we we've trying to close out
you know Dallas at the end of the game
put on defense to get the ball back give
off is another opportunity that's also
how my mindset well sure just another
opportunity give very often to another
chance well I guess that's another way
for me to get into the fact that all
season long we're gonna be talking about
it anytime that there's a pass
interference penalty that gets
challenged right I mean it is totally it
is totally changing
way that this game is gonna get
officiated this fall and I got a little
glimpse of you know how it's going to go
based on having spoken to Al River on he
presented to the NFL Network the NFL
Media Group how this is gonna work and
how just like instant replay reviews
anything that is reviewable once you
open that once you go under the hood as
they used to say once you start replay
anything that's reviewable can be
replayed and reviewed just like if you
say hey that should be passed
interference and they catch offensive
pass interference they're gonna call
that too so like the Chris Jones hit on
Tom Brady would they review that they
will not because it's not reviewable mmm
it's not it's not reviewable a hit on a
quarterback what is reviewable would be
well we caught 12 men on the field
what's reviewable is offensive pass
interference like so if you're gonna try
and get a defensive pass interference
call they might come back and say you
know what we can't pick up that
defensive pass interference flag but
there's also offensive pass interference
offsetting penalties so this is the sort
of stuff that said their sources you do
you like this concept and look at of
evolution of of a game you have an
outcome that's gonna happen now when you
have something like what finished our
game you could hope that there could be
a review situation you know you figure
you've got the best referees on the
field who's gonna make the best calls
and when they don't that's where
scrutiny comes and now you're taking it
to a higher power
hopefully that higher power is correct
well would you want let's put it this
way also would you want holding reviewed
I mean it comes back to bite us in the
blood I mean that's gonna suck but at
the end the day you know it created this
change and that's all you can ask for in
the future would you would would you
wanna say holding gets reviewable I
might have to say yes just because of
what happened to us but at the end day
again I can see either way if you're let
your gonna let players play and let
players play if you're gonna review
everything let's just you know as long
as the level playing field Cameron
Jordan here in the Rich Eisen show the
latest word in the world of collective
bargaining between the players and
ownership is that the NFL has put on yes
the CBA
that the players that the owners have
put on the table
the concept of an 18-game schedule but
you're already laughing six but they're
only gonna make you play 16 games that
somehow you figure out you don't play
two of the 18 how would that even work
have we talked about this so you have so
people come to a game to watch Drew
Brees throw it and Michael Thomas - do
you know a K take off from the backfield
or catch out of the backfield up rising
stars to play
you've got starters that are only gonna
play for 16 games if you present 18
games I'm like that's gonna be a
terrible idea and four how does that
even work like oh I'm gonna take these
two weeks off like week eight through
ten I'm gonna take off
eight nine I guess I'm gonna take off as
a competitor as an ultimate competitor I
never want to be off the field so you're
not gonna tell me I'm not gonna be out
of a game especially when I have my
brothers who we gonna go through
training camp with or you know people
that were you bleed sweat and win with
you're not gonna tell me I'm gonna be
out for to go games it's not gonna
happen so now I'm playing 18 games and
is there compensation for this it brings
in too many aspects 18 games which you
only had to play 16 I don't know how it
would work honest with you and there is
there is talk that quarterbacks might be
exempt from this that they would play
all 18 games because they're already if
you will protected enough hmm I don't
understand how it would work all I know
is that I wouldn't it would mess if a
quarterback has now an 18-game schedule
would mess with the history books it
would just mess with everything no doubt
there's too much the games but I would
assume you would be compensated for it
in the matter that more revenue comes in
and the Players Association get a cut of
that revenue
I'm assuming that that's the way it
would work drew it though for 6,000
yards instead of 5,000 yards it's boy
you're giving him 500 yards a game for
those extra two games huh I mean he's a
pro that's very odd I know you think
he's you know great but I'm just I'm
just simply saying is he so 300 I'm
really just giving him six
really just give him 20 20 a game by the
way I wouldn't put it past him he's he's
the all-time leader in 400-yard games
and thought I'm sure 500-yard game just
thrown off the top might I bet he is the
all-time leader right in 500 he's throw
300 yards so like I said I'm really just
getting my 7 honey I'll break down 2
games with 350 I'm just what we're
sticking just real briefly on the
business of things are you hearing
anything that there's a CVA conversation
going
honestly anything you could share here
honestly I've heard rumbles and talks
but at this point it's all it's all just
hearsay you know I'm sure when we get
our NFL PA rep talked to Craig Robertson
you know we'll talk to Ernie Khan well
we'll talk to all of our guys
that's inclusively in these in the NFLPA
and we'll be more knowledgeable about it
at this point I don't think there's
anything cemented so I'm sort of I'm
sort of just like wait wait till
something that weights just wait you see
Cameron Jordan of the New Orleans Saints
here on the Rich Eisen show okay so the
goal it's got to be Super Bowl or bust
this year right I mean I know it's very
microphone but I mean it's Super Bowl
bust every year right but I feel like
every the past two years you know we hit
a deep into the playoffs two years ago
we weren't one game further last year
into a conference championship game so
all we have to do is go one game further
and we'll be in a Super Bowl being the
place that we were shooting for when we
talked about our ability to get to the
Super Bowl I think we have all the right
pieces you're talking about coming out
the backfield Alvin Kamara you lose Mark
Ingram but you add latavius Murray you
have Mike Thomas you've got trae Quan
and headed into a second year Ted Ginn
will be healthy this year you know you
talk about our tight end situation we
picked up a strong tight end we extended
Josh Josh Hill we've got a lot of great
things going for us on offense and then
you talk about our defense
you know how well our linebacker corps
will play our basically our entire
secondary will be the same starters as
they were last year and that's something
that we haven't seen in and while
they're all from Ohio State right last
night I think
stayed and then you had them tie you
Buckeyes it's pretty amazing no doubt
and your first four is ridiculous I mean
you got the whole Monday nighter against
Houston then you're at the Rams at
Seattle home for Dallas I mean on a
Sunday night ooh
think I don't know you don't know I know
me the first game of the Texas I don't I
can't look beyond the first game oh it's
my job to do I guess so we have the
texture you've given me the one game at
a time thing did you always one game at
a time I don't know who we played
pre-season Cameron Jordan you and I go
what too far back for you to come on
this show and give me the one game
that's all I got to focus on well at the
Rams at the Seahawks home for the
Cowboys home for the Bucs that's a
stretch at the Jaguars at the Bears here
comes Carl Amari what do you think of
that idea I Lamar a 5-10 minute and a
quarter they haven't announced him as a
starter right oh they're playing they're
playing that I'm the same get in trouble
but you know Steve kind the general
manager was kind enough to call in the
Monday after the draft and say yes he is
the storm right quarterback cuz lets you
know they you don't you don't you don't
you don't kick out the number 10 for
number one did not make him the starter
he yes no doubt but 5 10 and a quarter
but he's got all sorts of skills
what is Russ Wilson Russ is like five
nine I mean what do you think I think
he's a baller I mean you know height
means nothing when you you can evade it
and be elusive in the pocket and then
throw dimes and I mean I've seen you
know I've seen clips of him throw in
dime pieces right so this is Russell
Wilson the toughest guy for you to say
yeah because all the office of linemen
are like six five and above and then
Russ is out here skirting around like
running back and then throwing these
these laser dimes now you know luckily I
would say luckily but I mean fortunate
for us I feel like our secondary strong
enough to compete with their wide
receiver core especially now that you
know Doug Baldwin is retired now did you
have Tyler Lockett and so by the way oh
you so you talked about you know rest is
out there making moves I mean he's a
loose in the pocket and I mean his pay
reflects what is either the highest pay
is that sir ever
he is absolutely and well you got
yourself can I get a hot tub my kid is
throwing the ball
baseball football basketball we're how
old is yours or no monster is four four
yeah what's his name
tank tank Jordan tank had to fight hard
for that conversation Caleb but come on
okay so so legally real name tank guys
go by the middle name all the time okay
so I asked you about the CBA
negotiations I had no idea
more delicate negotiations you've been a
part of know des hommes so you what's
what's your wife's name
Nikki okay you sat down what she used to
be a speed see you kick that out of
there last name punt it so you sit down
you say Nikki I'd like to name our son
tank is that how this went ah it was
like we had like three or four names you
know everything from like Bo and then I
started playing out with it it was like
Theodore grandfather's name was Theodore
sure and then it was like somebody else
it was like a couple of T's and I was
like what about Titan you know I just
started out there she's like Titan so I
sort of liked that I was like yeah like
you know he's gonna be a monsters person
Titan so it would go with it I was like
what about tank and she just like it's
like well I've got his first name right
and the so so we just sort of leveraged
first name versus middle name so she
took over first name and gave my man on
an incredible credit score out of gates
with Caleb and then I hit him with tank
I'll say if he's anything like he could
be a great lawyer take Jordan sounds
like a guy I would love to you know go
to battle for me yes tank Jordan exhaust
sound like you don't want any peace any
peace I agree my guys monstrous he's
four he's four he's like wearing size
seventies or whatever it is in kids
he's monsters I have been in the very
same negotiation with you sir I had two
boys first my wife and I had two boys
Lucas my wife said we got a try for a
girl and I saw it to myself the concept
of we have to like what do you what do
you like
no she's we have to try for the girl
hears it she says if we try for the girl
we got the girl
you can name her
we try for the girl thank goodness we
got the girl okay and then my naming
rights Scott immediately demoted to the
middle name oh wait so you went from
getting the first two to just know that
I was gonna get the first okay then I
got the second and I went with Mattingly
the name of my favorite baseball player
of all time Don Mattingly okay so her
name is Taylor Mattingly Eisen and her
initials are tme which is too much Eisen
which he happen is and it it's all
worked out in the end
team I like that so sometimes the middle
name is it's not too bad that's what I'm
saying I mean you can go I'll say and
you can go by your middle name I mean
you know I went by my middle name too
got to high school is that what is your
middle name yeah Tyler nice you a
tireless Jordan for all those years
that's awesome and all all three first
names hi every Tyler Joey I'll be with
you and this is no disrespect I don't
know if Tyler Jordan gets for Pro Bowl
seasons in his first date I know you
probably would've got six pops we've
been good Tyler Tyler gets into Cal no
matter what no doubt Tyler Tyler is
there all right I'm regardless I'd like
to keep you one more segment if you
don't mind you have to go somewhere
I don't okay I think the next place you
go is the NFL Network and I'ma
personally personally apologize into my
colleagues just all right when we come
back I want to talk about your Madden
rating and then your affinity for the
same line that I have as well
love it Jordan and I saw you I just
visited the ring but I have yet to get
that invitation
I can make Cabo back with Cameron don't
call me Tyler I'm the dad of tank Jordan
no doubt when we're back on the Rich
Eisen show in a moment Cameron Jordan
here on the Rich Eisen show let's put it
up on the screen right here your Madden
race to happen what do we have what are
we looking right so Madden ratings are
released today top-ten defensive lineman
Cameron Jordan you are 991 tied with
Myles Garrett and Gino African
Aaron Donald great okay JJ what Captain
America
Fletcher Cox a force max is 95 that's
impressive
Callay is 92 so you're telling me me and
Cole a us are you one apart
my K Michael Pearce of the Ravens is 92
I know you don't want to denigrate your
fellow teammates but if you do yeah
we're not here for this negativity I'm
just gonna accept it fellow your fellow
players no look I know nine out of the
top ten okay Michael Pearce 91 there you
go see Michael Pearce right now at fry
if I might tell to foe it seems like the
wait about just flat-out denigrated
colleagues fellow I mean I mean you have
a tutelage under terrell suggs for so
many years you're gonna be a great
defensive it look at that camera the
cardinals you know he's from a high
school well he doesn't claim us
he's from my right behind school again
still hurts in the two minutes I have
left the Jordan vineyard made some
tremendous juice we met in a Los Angeles
event recently absolutely now you
visited the vineyard I definite it took
the little ATV and smashed through the
whole twelve hundred acre situation
while you're in Sun gosh it's a TV I was
rocked a couple greats a new vintage
holding up the bottle right there the
Jordan house elude the is this the
vintage you sent to Cam Cameron Newton
did you send that to Cam Newton where
after you swept them this is the 2015
with the French oak okay it wasn't out
yet okay I'm not a he didn't catch the
French okay shot the mayor did you ever
hear back from cam after sentiments not
of course not I just
I saw his I saw his cleats the last time
he lost and then yeah that's sort of the
sort of the end of it hmm that's by the
way that's you didn't send a thank-you
note
thanks for the right no some say it's a
phenomenal bottle of water view Oh water
would you yeah right exactly
it's a phenom battle wine you know I
feel like it pairs well with everything
it's light is that gonna be your calling
card from now on when you sweep I'm
gonna send them some Jordan wine I feel
like I probably owe a quarterback
something I probably should said Matt
one you said you Sardi sent Matt clear
you see in week one he's with Houston no
ooh yeah you could do that in advance a
week one I'm sure I was thinking Matt
Ryan
quarterbacks like Oh Lyman don't like
he's not gonna appreciate wine is these
five burgers in off it's a lot
Wow there are some I don't know exactly
what you're eating is to sustain that
type of weight you're not counting
calories
all right well Taco Tuesday everyday
thanks for thanks for the stop by thanks
for letting me she ate the healthy
banter at all times at any time at cam
Jordan 94 number nine Stephen come on
and you know if the microphones off you
would absolutely denigrate some of the
players lifting you're very boosting
each other every class even if we don't
know who you are for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app